have you ever figured out this riddle a
it's a riddle to me but it's not in a
way that have you have you ever noticed
that when you decide that you are
supposed to teach something whether
you're teaching it to your kids whether
you're teaching it to a friend whether
you may be teaching a little Sunday
School class or you're teaching some Boy
Scouts or Girl Scouts to get their badge
or whatever it is there's a lot of
different places that you and I teach we
don't necessarily have to be a paid
teacher in the classroom we all share
ideas and teach and share opinions and
when you get ready to do that have you
noticed that you end up learning more
about the thing you're teaching then you
knew before just by getting ready to
teach by the fact you teach it you learn
more about it there's no question about
that 20-some odd years doing this on the
radio show doing this radio show that
answering questions that people bring a
question I don't know the answer and I
got to go get that I got to go dig in I
got to learn or just to get ready to do
a show on a given day you know the
things we read and stay on top of our
team does research and you know just to
be prepared to do a good job for you the
listener you have to get ready and you
know I've had that experience this year
and I realized it I think in the last
three or four weeks it's kind of been
fuzzy in my brain and somehow it came
clear over the over the weekend and what
what I realized was about this time last
year I guess it was or the year before
we started putting together the
curriculum for the legacy journey which
is the class that follows up Financial
Peace University after you go through
Financial Peace University you ought to
go through this and it teaches you about
wealth building and it teaches you about
wealth and it teaches you about
generational wealth and it teaches you
about a legacy and a little bit about
estate planning and those kinds of
things and so I had to learn and dig
into some of those things a little
deeper than I already knew but more than
anything else they just became top of
mind and when you kind of just start
have something bouncing around in your
noodle you begin to see things you
didn't see before and I thought I was
healed of this
but I wasn't and what is this well one
of the things we talk about in the
legacy journey is a proper biblical view
of wealth wealth is owned by God it is
given to you to manage to do his work
now if you're not a believer I
understand that you have a differing
opinion on that I'm fine but it's a
class the legacy journey is a class has
taught in churches and so it is a
Christian class and so we're looking at
well through a biblical lens which is
how a lot of people in America still
view things
the vast majority by the way and even if
they're not quote church people or our
quote Christians unquote they still kind
of have that ethic the judeo-christian
ethic on how they view things and so in
other words we kind of all mostly agree
that that wealth is not to be just used
only for selfish desires that that makes
you a selfish jerk if you spend a
hundred percent of it on you
you'd be called a hedonist and most of
us would call you a jerk if you build
great wealth that's sharing it is one of
the beauties of having done that at some
level now once you get past that though
boom the whole thing disintegrates and
you get into this whole wealth
inequality thing with these people
whining and moaning about the
one-percenters and people that you know
my everything life's not fair everybody
should get a trophy and when and and and
then and then and anime including the
president and on and on and on with this
whole thing and so there's a whole
movement that's kind of anti success
anti capitalism out there because they
don't think wealth is fair or wealth is
fun because everyone doesn't have the
equal amount and a bunch of fascist I
guess they would have everybody dressing
alike walking alike talkin alike and
having the exact same level of talents
and results it's absolutely ridiculous
and so but I thought I was kind of had
that position I thought I'm done with
that I feel okay about being successful
I know the way we've become successful
serving other people but I didn't
realize in the back of my mind rattling
around was this kind of thing like if I
get something nice I must have done
something wrong you ever kind of thought
that that like you work your butt off
and you save your money and then you go
by finally a nice car that the muffler
doesn't fall off of
and you kind of feel like you did
something wrong because somewhere
there's a starving kid somewhere there's
somebody that's homeless and you kind of
feel like did I do something wrong did I
did i mess up somehow and I know I'm
intellectually above that in a sense of
not not but I bet there's that little
kid inside of either goes gosh have I
have I have I harmed someone no I didn't
harm anybody you have to stop in to a
gut check I hope people and nobody
griped about it when I sold 10 financial
piece books and I made a buck apiece but
when I sold 10 million of them made a
buck apiece
people got mad and I held and that means
I hope 10 million people instead of
helping 10 but people got mad then and
it's weird it's just weird this view on
this anti success movement and
everything should be fair and the little
man can't get ahead in this victim
mentality and all this stuff floating
around and and then I got attacked by a
couple of Christian bloggers and a
couple of bloggers on CNN and all this
stuff and ripping me back and forth
about you know Dave Ramsey hates poor
people and all this which is a bunch of
crap
obviously we help people for poor people
for a living it's what we do and but
that made me you know I got pissed off
then and so it made me go I'm going to
relook at this again because I wonder if
there's something and you know there's a
there's a scripture in you know well
start with Craig Groeschel my buddy out
in Oklahoma City has a great saying and
we use it in the legacy journey he says
why is it that the only blessing from
God that we apologize for is wealth when
God blesses someone with wealth why are
they supposed to apologize now that I'm
excluding jerks and crooks okay if
somebody stole something or they harmed
someone to get their wealth that's not
what I'm talking about but if some guy
has a heating and air company and he
grew it to 20 cities and he's serving
people in 20 cities versus one truck
why should he apologize if he has a
restaurant he does a good job and he
franchises it into a hundred cities and
he helps a hundred people get a nice
meal at a reasonable value why should he
apologize or she apologized and I'm just
not going to why is it the only blessing
from God we apologize for his wealth
Ecclesiastes says here's what I've seen
it's a
good and fitting for one to eat and to
drink and to enjoy the good of all his
labour and which he toils Under the Sun
all the days of his life which God gives
him for it is his heritage as for every
man to whom God has given riches and
wealth and given him power to eat of it
to receive his heritage and to rejoice
in his labour this is the gift of God so
you should build wealth and you should
do good with the wealth and help others
you should be outrageously generosity in
generous but you also ought to take your
wife on a freaking Cruise and you ought
to buy her one of those ridiculous
purses that cost too much and and you
ought to buy yourself that sports car
you were wanting and that's ok
and so here's my message to you today
don't apologize for being successful
don't apologize for going into the
marketplace and winning and I promise
you I won't either this is the Dave
Ramsey show
you
you